hello everybody my name is Markiplier
the baby in your
in your black cat
this got enough
right into it across the shore in
distant lands I saw a cat
this isn't
okay
uh oh hi this shake is nauseating
are you oh okay
oh
yeah
[Music]
hi oh
hi
in their absence
I'm not sure if I've listened to that
before but I don't have time for that
ah I have vague Recollections of this
and if you have vague Recollections of
this that means you watch the Black and
Yellow
the baby in yellow but this is the Black
Cat which is an evolution of that
for the next DLC or whatever you want to
call these days hi Kitty well you're a
doll
hi baby
bye baby
so we're going into some kind of a void
with a kitty cat
and I have vague Recollections of this
too but I don't know why maybe this just
looks like The Stanley Parable
hi Kitty uh
yeah
interesting
oh
I hope there wasn't something happening
in that Moon because I looked away at
exactly the wrong time
okay
hi again man I've been on a jerk okay
did I pass that I'm awake now
sure wish I knew what the hell was going
on book
why do I have a book
foreign
baby
they can't do a zoom in jump scare thank
you
June 2nd uh look 940 painting travel
continues to be the best way to Journey
Between Worlds
I must stay hidden from the child
I risk the same fate as the others
it's hard not to worry about being
doctor
that's not to dwell on it hi Kitty hi
hello
all right so we got a three oh that goes
there obviously
grab some nuts and bolts why
oh not Unlimited
cool don't know what that's for
foreign
seems like I'm gonna have to craft
something eventually
oh but not now
possibly do it now
um far too busy solving whatever the
hell this is hmm far too busy uh this
doesn't make any sense
wait that's not right
that's not right at all
so am I supposed to do something with
these
Newt missing shutdown okay
all right
hey
all right never mind
research heavily impacted yeah
[Music]
wow good log
grade log buddy grade log
okay so if I can't do anything there and
I can't Jam this in the plug and I can't
zap myself
then what do I do I don't have the right
book to be able to do the thing and none
of these tools seem to be able to help
me operate the computer and you're not
helping me you piece of crap
hammer
oh what is that there's only one other
book and it doesn't work
unless it does work and I'm just stupid
oh it was a different book oh it was
another book I'm taking an oil can
I can't see what a different book
thou
uh-huh
Cole
oh God
I really goofed that right at the end
there all right let's try it one more
time full shove cold shove cold shove
cold shove and then twist
oh nice all right
so that's open now
not sure what this is for
oh
great
fantastic I love
sewers
[Music]
that was a classic jump scare sound and
I don't appreciate it
that was just a plain old jump scare how
in the world does a cat make a sound
like that it's not diegetic
appreciate anything that's not diabetic
that sounds pretty diegetic to me
who's diegetically fashioned on that
door
oh
foreign
well that looks deadly or peen-like it
was up kitty
oh it's horrible it's horrible durable
is horrible oh your heart is broke oh
well I don't care all right Flora of
carcosa
Light reading will take my mind off of
this
ink cartridge oh
oh battery
well that's just too convenient
huh
334.
it's proving to be one of my most
valuable Creations is how Harvest
although I do
best keeps some spares on hand
am I right
it's not really a battery design flaw
when it just runs out of batteries that
seems like actually how normal things
function when they run out of batteries
here you go
oh
oh no he's brain damaged oh well that's
a shame uh can you stop staring at me I
know you're probably supposed to be
adorable but in reality you are very
horrible and I don't like looking at you
and I don't like your eyes
I think this is the problem that Scott
gothan ran into when he tried to make uh
wholesome religious games and he ended
up making horrible nightmares
yeah
yeah I'm saying good I like the way your
arms slop though
okay what do we got here oh
okay
uh
if
weird
ah of course right
oh that's even worse
tap
what do you mean
oh okay oops
well the new doesn't like this
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
wow that was a fun mini game
that was great
Hi how are you my name is I don't want
to hug you oh
God
okay
um oh yeah I know where those are
I'll be right back
perfect
uh here you go
why did you need oh that's so cute
that's how you talk
oh your ass oh
okay
ah
you're helpless and trembling with fear
eel
deal
it's like a baby
oh
no baby alone never mind you're not
what the [__] what the frick what kind
of drug trip you having oh horrible okay
I don't trust you I don't trust any of
this we're on a random switch because I
can got a book
I need a socket something goes in here
oh interesting
oh well it's a trap
hmm
ah booster unit almost handy
huh
dd1 can't be attached by hand well Frick
you too man
eat a dick
all right got a booster
aha
terrible
terrible ah terrible oh terrible no baby
sight
egotistical that I made the dolls look
like myself
login
well I mean how can you really say that
they look like you when they're wearing
a full costume that covers your face so
not really hello
oh wow the holy doors
[Music]
oh yeah
wow that was really something
all right
whatever this is gonna do
missed
go
[Music]
uh-huh
yep uh goodbye
what the hell man I fixed you
I saved you you should at least give me
like some money or something or maybe
some subscribers or Shares are a little
low this month
I'm gonna go after I'm having to go
fight a baby oh wow oh wow oh wow hey
what's up
all right
okay
hey did you know that it was a baby
helping to repair the elevator
I you know this really doesn't give as
much cluage as you think if I didn't
have these other words up in the top
left of my brain I wouldn't know what
the hell you were talking about
okay see I don't know how but I'm
guessing you need a wrench
that's what I know you need
is close enough right
here
okay
hair
here
ah here
oh
if you can whistle why can't you just
talk to me
oil I know that one
my boo to you too
whatever
yeah okay next time you want something
like that you can just ask I thought
that was to fix the whatever
or you can go get it yourself no you did
ask me what I'm telling you is that I
don't want to help you anymore
I knew there were hammers around here
somewhere I saw hammers
hammers
you're gonna bash yourself in the head
with us
bye
so baby are you getting closer
should I be worried about this
oh
well that's nice
well done Newt
um
I guess I'm out of here
oh that's good
that's probably fine hi baby
hey you know I know I'm your babysitter
and all that
but
uh what can you do
[Music]
baby oh baby man oh no baby fine baby
baby fine baby
okay oh hi
hello
explore huh oh
wow
okay don't look at me like that
okay I don't know why I'm supposed
yellow
really such a fun word to say the yellow
this is the
yellow yellow yellow yellow log ND
okie dokie then that's yeah a good
exploration over there I'll be right
with you
well that was fun
I get on there
cool
wow
[Music]
what kind of baby experiments do you
want me to perform so there's a flower
and then noodle make
uh it blew it's just Out Of Reach I I
can't jump I couldn't possibly down here
grab that
get that no
no
no please
no it's right there
dude all right fine
okay two reagents
need blue then red and then everything
else do I have long grabby arms
um
out of the Unspeakable
should I be driven Madden
and I leave this recording ass
never opened the door
and never allow the gyrosphere to stop
spinning
if the Rings ever so much as waiver
he will find you
um
yeah I think there are
I don't think that qualifies as spinning
and also what door are you talking about
because uh
I don't know what door you mean uh
bottle um
that's unhelpful
okay we need reagents for that
something
okay
flower
nude
please
I don't know what you're doing dude but
that's Oh weird
all right it looks dead
now it does okay
am I supposed to feel bad about that
because I really don't heat it up
this feels like animated the Dark
Descent
fun
all right
oh
I don't know why that was necessary
I don't know Brew
uh-huh oh
okay fine
[Music]
oh my God
what was that supposed to be oh hi oh
there you are hey you want a bottle
there you go here oh you're gonna be
magnetized oh look at you
look at you
you're magnetic and magnificent oh
you're done
hi baby
hi baby yellow oh it's okay it's not
like I threw you or anything like that
can I send you through the tube
all right
oh no
I don't know if that was good whatever
all right what do we got oh not an
emergency okay
open the oven
no I'm not thinking about it
that's not what I'm thinking at all I
would never put the baby in the oven
in oven who would do that there'd be
monstrous it doesn't matter how much of
a demon baby it is you would never do
that who could do that
that'd be so mean
oh man
turkey
whoa my God
damn
[Music]
God what happened to my turkey
all right
that's uh
there's a turkey all right
hey Bobby are you still over there you
want turkey
maybe got a turkey for you you want
turkey here you go baby wow
all right you have fun with that
don't worry I didn't have any weird
thoughts oh baby mad all right I didn't
have any concerning ideas why wouldn't I
have
April 4th log 566. right
people back from
carquette could just be the reagent
that I can trick with my
Quest
to the chess pyramids
no salvation
yeah
this seems good
I am a babysitter that wants to feed a
myriad of concoctions would you like a
concoction
oh oh oh oh oh oh
well that wasn't
that wasn't bad all right you set up
right there
got a pickle you know pickle there you
go
[Music]
why does that happen
there you go
yeah cheese
there you go that's good okay what was I
doing I know that there was a uh uh it
was like a uh there was like um
a valve here
somewhere
half the building ceiling
's parties
the bathroom was in that house
nah that sucks man
that's rough uh where'd that Vel go
there it is okay so this is supposed to
go somewhere
I just got to figure oh
oh
if I send the baby through that specific
spot
then it's gonna get us somewhere no
hey wait a minute
wait baby you didn't
oh I know what needs to be done
all right we're going to time this up
perfectly you're gonna get that and I'm
gonna turn this and you're gonna go in
there and you're gonna grab it whoosh
that's how we do even though you might
stick to the walls
what a silly game what a silly game
what a silly silly game what
what is that supposed to be yeah I got a
I got a candle
purple candle oh
okay
uh
uh is that supposed to do something oh
ah get on there
Wham
hey get on there
oh all right
it's not that oh
oh see hey wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait
[Music]
wait wait hey
Bravo right there
ah
oh interesting
may I
baby
baby it's okay oh it's okay don't worry
you're pretty high up and that's pretty
scary but if you fall down you're gonna
survive
oh no poor baby
oh no poor baby fell down
no
maybe you not feeling so good
wee who's a fun baby please you wanna go
through the tube that'll make you feel
better go through the tube
whoo
there you go that was fun
okay good baby
all right so I just got uh there you go
you're happy again Newt Newt Newt thank
you I am using you for your battery yes
and it's very cruel but I don't care
no no no
all right descent okay Newt get back
here
would you go Newt there you are
foreign
so I don't really know the order of this
but I got a square I've got some bow
looking thing I've got um you coming
with me and you're going over there
right there
okay so I got some kind of diamond bow
yada yada
no yep no oops yep okay so this makes it
easier I think square one right oh
[Music]
baby
well she's a particularly curious
creature uh whether she has motives or a
master sword
no
here's intelligent
I really hope she stays oh my God
oh I hate that
oh my God
ravaged by into the abyss adrift ravaged
by mental Tempest fell off a ladder
uh-huh
[Music]
terrible horrible
horrible
I don't like it oh
good
sure
that's fine oh hi
ah that was fun remember when I threw
you off of a ladder
yeah oh oh discover the secrets of
Photography okay
to be open at the front
all right
differences in perspective all right
baby you wait right there
I'll get your picture don't worry it's
not a very entertaining backdrop but
it's okay
we'll have to do
oh baby
all right camera film
oh look at this
wow
[Music]
I wonder if that's going to be helpful
room isn't dark enough
what is it
what is it oh
my God
oh
what
what the frick what was that baby what
the hell was that
God damn
oh [__]
oh [__] okay cool
love that all right baby let's do this
again oh wow Wham
all right
[Music]
that's pretty cool
oh
look at that
look at that what else can I do
[Music]
all right baby come here
we're gonna take a picture okay we're
gonna take a picture you got a book
you're looking very professional okay
that's very good oh Wham
got it
all right baby privacy please
no
[Music]
I'll cherish that memory forever wow
look at what you did you did it what did
you do I don't know anyway here's a
switch
whoa region flower
give it looks dead well I know how to
fix that don't I baby don't die baby
don't die
whoa luscious I know right I know anyway
go away baby
hmm all right oh well that looks mean
[Music]
Oh I thought you were pink
yeah whatever
okay what is this gonna do to the baby
hi baby keep a close eye this is gonna
be probably horrifying
so we've got a couple combinations we
could do red and green that's fun
oh there we go
all right we've got some kind of cyan
is that right
is that what red and green make
oh
you wanna be happy hey baby oh no
baby no baby
ah
ah but I know how you can help though
okay
good God are you oh
brick
all right okay but that's gonna be kind
of helpful that's kind of nice
if I have a bunch of the oh nope it's
one one use only ow but
okay hold on all right baby oh hold on
hold on
hold on is this even gonna be able to
work for you oh wow it did
strong demands
ah hold ah
shoot oh but it's fine
I'm free
wow
I'm free in memory of the Fallen The
Seekers of the jaundice Court Eternal
watch yellows Bane hey baby I think they
didn't like here but um
I think you're welcome
oh can I shoot the baby with a cannon I
don't know if this is a good idea but
I'm ideating
ganoush
all right well
um
it's not really aimed properly uh baby
if you could just
sit right here
okay there's got to be a way that I can
aim it over to the gate because I'm
assuming that's what I'm supposed to do
March 12th
the view from the garden and the and the
Black Star I've had is a mesmerizing
sight
I hope and find myself
wondering when my time will come
I must persevere
that is pretty cool also your logs are
really short
but that is really cool that's nice I
like that it's not the traditional just
a chromatic aberration what is it
it's like just has a red Hue around it
it's really nice
that's cool oh flower
well I don't even know if I'm gonna be
able to get you inside
hi
oh
oh new
dude wait newt's on a rampage I knew you
keep this up don't worry I got it I got
him here we go
all right I'll keep it ready as soon as
he's there oh I'm blasting him
okay it doesn't seem to be working okay
clearly there's something else going on
here new uh
uh you bloodthirsty robot come here
oh you look mad
[Music]
what if I load you in here can I load
you in here
I don't know what's gonna happen but
this is what's happening
hold
wait a minute I know what to do come
here you
[Music]
wait
I don't know what's gonna
get him
and new really wants them put baby on
nuke oh
what and now what
ah of course oh
so we are blasting the baby into
Oblivion
fascinating
oh my God bye baby
uh
uh that seems like a sane thing for a
robot to suggest that was very good
all right
beautiful
oh
Woody man you mad oh you're mad uh oh
thanks dude
oh
maybe the baby shouldn't have been such
a bad baby
ah a baby
you okay Newt also you are right oh no
oh
okay
uh
oh
um
that's normal oh oh you're fine oh
you're not you're fine
oh you're fine
are you fine
seem fine oh
you had me thinking that everything was
horrible
but everything is fine yes hi
it's been literally one minute how did
you make all these things
okay purple Plus
I don't know probably blue or something
let's go Blue
yeah hello
I'm the best
hey baby
[Music]
there you go baby
oh I stabilize the gyrosphere I did not
you
wow is this an emergency is this one of
those emergencies not an emergency all
right you way right there baby so oh I
need to stabilize the gyrosphere ah
Newt is scared but why though
all right so what if I feed you another
one of those bottles do you get all
fiery because you burned up all the
stuff so I'll give you another one of
these pop that in there you're on fire
and then send you upstairs so
oh wait did the baby just drop it whoa
okay
oops
are you take that
um was there another one around here
somewhere anybody seen anything uh to
burn maybe if I just bring him over
maybe that would do it
burn
oh that's all it takes
fascinating
it's okay baby don't be sad it's fine
everything's good
oh oh baby gone oh
hi baby
[Music]
ow ow why baby baby
hey
you're gonna be such a douche
right
baby
[Music]
you're being a real pain in the butt oh
the past it's an emergency right
it's an emergency
no wow okay geez
hey baby
if you could just behave for a little
bit
um
like uh there you go
oh
nap time
okay arrival
arrive ah sure that'll do something
uh yep okay keep the Rings spinning
okidokey then
uh
um then one of these okay
uh it hides us from the King it protects
us from the baby
okay so there's gotta be like an order
that you do it in right
let's try this
oh
[Music]
mmm
there we go easy peasy
it's almost like these puzzles are for
babies
oh wait that's not stable
that's not spinning either
hey
hey [__]
do not open do not open keep the door
sealed okay
whatever you say even though I'm pretty
sure that orb that just fell down there
is a perfect sigh or a basketball I
can't pick it up
I think it's the perfect size oh really
baby oh really baby
oh
oh that's not good oh that uh wow
[Music]
dokie dokie then
um uh oh well
oh I can what I uh it wasn't working
before what
brace the door with what oh the door
stop
perfect
get a boost up oh
hello
retrieve the core head outside
never mind oh you fell
not with me oh that's a problem
maybe I shouldn't be there but
apparently he's fine
that's probably fine
come with me buddy we're gonna get out
of here not safe to pick up oh
dude go find the missing pieces
all right Newt don't do anything I guess
thanks Newt really appreciate you
contributing to the cause
am I doing that with my mind or
something
whoa okay all right well let's get out
of here here give the new your new
ticket
oh God
oh
wait a minute oh wait oh that's a
problem
well you see how I didn't know which way
to go
take a note
I'm coming no way
you think the baby can't fly upstairs or
else we'd be doomed
oh man that was a close one thank
goodness we're safe and sound forever oh
that's fair I got this one don't you
worry about a thing
uh
uh I I whoa
uh should I do this thing is this what
I'm doing it's too big
oh I see
you got this buddy
uh-huh
Wham
ah
thank you
[Music]
no no
no no no
no
dude you can fit in this report
[Music]
oh
no how dare you make me care about this
character what is happening
nude look
where you at right there newt
okay
all right Newt note
note
oh wait I need nude
[Music]
why did you bring him here
I don't
know I don't know
walk
somehow I cared about a newt and I don't
know I made some bad decisions
I see now that it said very much not to
do all that stuff
um
so yeah I see I see how that's my fault
and I am sorry okay but pretty good
obviously some Polish went into that so
the developers are really sticking up
their game anyway thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought down in the comments below if
you want to see more the baby in yellow
I played it before thank you and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]